you
[Music]
today's talk will be by initial oda
trying to Q&A roster and he said i don't
have money and i guess we saw yesterday
in class class see this he's meeting
he's an expert in while they're sensing
that his work on wireless networks and
since the sense of sensing networks in
the past right past twenty years
Anisha has been using microsoft research
for the last twenty years again and from
or together they've been spending spent
ten years on collecting will building
the hardware ecosystem and the datasets
well you know thank you thank you for
the invitation and it's great to be at
Microsoft with all these wonderful minds
and to meet all friends and run into
lots of new folks and great new ideas by
the way twenty years ago we started
working on device networks at Microsoft
so Bill Gates had his own home network
and different groups in Microsoft were
coming up with their own version so
research human Randy and I were working
on device networks and somehow that
attracted our foes attention which got
me to working in wireless sensor
networks before that I did distributed
computing and theory so building things
is something I credit Microsoft to
getting me into so so yesterday you know
we spoke about the role of Mort scale
computing and how it leverages machine
learning and it's poised to leverage
deep learning so today I really won't
focus on deep learning I'll just pick up
on that topic of issues we've run into
using shadow machine learning at mode
scale and these issues are phrased in
terms of this concept of limited signals
which is a vague concept but I'll try to
give you different conceptions of
limited signal and how it impacts the
design question yeah so just as a recap
mode scale is battery powered stuff
you've got
you know radios your your wireless the
consumption of power is limited it's
typically well below 100 milliwatts now
you could use energy harvesting you have
one or more sensors you have one or more
processors so so just to illustrate the
details of one type of mode here is
something that we have been using you
know for a decade or so we use systems
like these small 8-bit motes you know
from from SE TI and and used an
operating system called tiny OS which
was a remarkable concept for being
resource-constrained and it turned out
tiny OS even though we trained thousands
of students didn't transition very well
quite simply because it was not easy to
program yeah so here you have the
challenge of addressing low power and
this low power can exploit all these
rich these rich low power modes for
example this cortex m3 mode that we
called the B at some rocks called the
dot now mode has really nice low-power
States and it's really a software design
challenge to be able to exercise those
low-power States correctly yeah so to
address this issue that it was hard to
get people to change how they program
you know we had to revert to a standard
programming language we said we would
work in in C shop yeah so we actually
took a system which was built at
Microsoft Research about 20 years ago
it's called the dotnet micro framework
and we took the dotnet micro framework
can be stripped it and we made it
near-real-time
improved its jitter and added wireless
capabilities to it so what we've ended
up with is a runtime that we call the
emote where you can run at the moment
interpreted and not just in time
compiled c-sharp programs and we get
pretty decent jitter we can program
application specific networks and the
way we do this is by abstracting the
radio link as a virtual link and this
could be multiple radios so all links
are offered to the network pattern as a
virtual link and so you can custom
design
your network at an abstract level and so
with this framework for virtualization
and these very general network patterns
we can come up with a rich class of
wireless sensor networks yeah so so the
point I wanted to make was that a moat
is largely software designed in fact
even the sensors are becoming largely
software designed and of course
programming the application at this high
level is a convenience that we would
like to build on so so yes okay so you
know as you noticed I showed you
yesterday the the radar array the radar
is actually just giving a simple complex
value right but this complex value
represents the the cumulative returns in
some in some region yeah now how do I
control that region should I actually
introduce those knobs in hardware and
exercise some kind of hardware tuning or
I can program those those knobs in
software so so this particular radar has
an FPGA and most of the sensor control
is in the software itself yeah and
increasingly you'll find that that's the
right pattern for leveraging the sensors
right yeah and in you know this is a
somewhat counterintuitive but we keep
thinking of digital MEMS as encoding in
Hardware more and more complex
computation but in fact sometimes just
beginning with a much lower power analog
MEMS and doing the rest and software is
not only more flexible but also lower
power so software-defined sensing is the
thing that you know we can build on
although you know it continues to grow
at the mote scale yeah it isn't the it
isn't the dominant pattern but what we
are finding is it's a very useful
pattern at mote scale and of course all
the features that you generate as all of
us are doing is done in software right
so we're not assuming that we are
limiting ourselves to some features
which are for example feature
like extracting certain filters which
are defined in the hardware itself you
are defining our own our own features so
so by limited signal what I mean is
various things yeah so one of the forms
of limited signal is I've got a signal
which is rather weak yeah so we are
looking at at targets which may not be
conceptually large we are in this low
power regime where this target compared
to the whole scene is rather small so
the signal in terms of power itself can
be quite small yeah now of course if
you've got an active sensor and the
active sensor is battery-powered it's
radiating at very low power yeah for
example in the case of the radar we are
radiating energy and the reflections are
coming back you know with a fourth power
of reduction so you've got signal which
is quite low in the presence of noise
and the key design challenges to find
how you can represent that signal in a
way that you get a good quality of SNR
to still be able to do your computing
tasks now in addition to the noise being
large the background environment
presents a lot of diversity and
magnitude of return yeah so we can think
of that as clutter yeah so we can place
our sensors in regimes where in addition
to the target is a large amount of
clutter which is contributing to
essentially a form of noise which we
have to reject now sometimes one can
make a distinction between the the
objects and the seen as being targets of
interest and targets not of interest so
there might be a distinction between
clutter and targets not of interest and
these targets sort of interest also have
to be rejected yeah so that also
constraints your your signal now if you
get into a sort of a more interesting
set of concerns this is when sensors can
interfere with each other yeah so so the
returns of an object can essentially be
interfering now that can happen in
multiple waves which I'll try and
outline
the talk but we'll have to think about
how how interference affects your design
now in certain cases you might think
about this interference as being
somewhat constructively or adversarially
done somewhat deliberately done yeah so
I'll define this concept called
obfuscation and now the question becomes
how do you deal with how do you leverage
our Fiske action is it is it a good
thing or a bad thing and of course
depends on your application and what can
you do about that and a form of
obfuscation can simply be spoofing
targets by constructively creating fake
targets on the scene rather than just
jamming the sensor so that's a very
rough definition of the kinds of
challenges we run into in applications
and I wanted to spell out how we've
thought about it really much of our work
is you know driven by the application
our methods are quite basic in some
cases and there's a lot of room for
growing this that could lead to an
interesting conversation so and what
applications is sort of incorrect I'll
just focus on one application given the
time today yeah so so the story about
why we got into forest protection is
really quite basic you know we've in the
last 40 years the wildlife of the world
has gone down by 70 percent yeah and one
way of reacting and this is it's not
just you know a sort of simple
ecological concern it is also an
economic concern yeah there are many
dimensions to this concern about how
human development is is being affected
by wildlife reduction and one way of
reacting to that problem is to deal with
large mammals yeah large mammals at the
top of the animal species hierarchy you
know have had this not only this this
attention that gets to people but in
fact if you're able to tame the damage
to them its contribution to the rest of
the chain is quite significant yeah so
so we ran into problems like in India in
2009 the tiger went extinct in certain
parts took them a few years to discover
it was extinct they were looking at bug
marks and they thought it was there
but in fact they were over counting the
same mark as being multiple Tigers so
they didn't realize the decline and they
didn't come up as being ready for it so
they had to do things like transplanting
Tigers so around 2011 we started this
project with a number of partners where
I was looking at radar sensor networks
my colleagues at IRC were looking at PIR
sensor networks my colleagues at
triple-i T Allahabad were looking at a
very cool fiber optic-based
classification of animal targets really
really good topic but that's for another
day so so the way we've this is a baby
formulation of the problem so you've got
you've got a reserve or or a national
park and in this part what you would
like to do is to see whether people or
animals are at points of interest
so there are crossing points where
either animals should not be or people
should not be and at these points of
interest you want to detect the activity
and in particular this activity has in
the sense of targets not of interest has
got to reject some types of activity
while focusing on other relevant types
of activity so for example in the
particular so we did one deployment in
the Panda National Reserve which is a
tiger reserve and then we did another
deployment in in 2016 in the in an
unnamed park in South Africa this was
done with the World Wildlife Fund and
the idea was here the poachers when they
come in they come in with dogs and they
come in in small groups of two or three
people so you had to discriminate these
poachers but when cattle were going
through the scene or goats were going
through the scene
you didn't have to alarm the guards now
it turns out there is not to my
knowledge
National Park or forest which is
uniformly covered by communications like
cellular yeah it turns out you're lucky
if at the guard stations you get
cellular or some network access yeah and
so we leverage that you let's assume the
guard station is connected we have these
operational points we want to do this
discrimination at the operational points
we
the guard station from the guard station
reached the cloud from the cloud contact
the management because guards have to be
kept honest and also if allowed contact
various social networks because a good
way of socializing the response to crime
is to actually good way to deal with
crimes to actually socialize the
response to that depending on how
progressive Park management's are now
for this system to work of course it had
to work in this hostile terrain you've
got a low-power Network which has to
cover large areas these parks tend to be
hundreds of square kilometres but knows
about 650 this part we were in was
probably about two-thirds of that and
and then you had to make sure that this
was easy to operate and to maintain
that's the key requirement because even
though you train the guards the guards
themselves have limited technical
competence cost is an important
constraint in the design because these
parks are very cash-strapped and to some
extent the adversary is very intelligent
yeah and it's very organised and it's
very legally supported yeah so you have
to be concerned about this hat being
somewhat stealthy accurate robust and
reliable so all these are issues and
that takes us as a motivation into the
limited signal case so here's how we
dealt with this we used this concept of
a virtual fence
although these parks are very large
often the crossings are happening in
small linear sections so for example in
this park in South Africa there was a
remote corner of the park where you had
a river which was very easily afforded
at certain times of the month yeah and
and there were certain four points so
there were many strips which were
roughly a hundred to 150 metres long so
if you could cover these 13 strips you
had covered one major zone yeah
sometimes you know you have a bunch of
watering holes and poisoning is a form
of of you know getting to the animal so
you had to detect what was going on at
the boys at the watering hole
alternatively a third pattern was that
there were these ingress routes where
you know people would actually drive in
come in fast shoot and head out yeah
this is a form of crime which is
particularly true in India where is the
poachers in South Africa they were
actually coming on foot and walking very
fast for significant distances yes so
again you know all these things are
deeply well understood right these
patterns are well known in fact the
organization is such that sometimes the
villagers are helping the poachers right
because of complex social relationships
right you can harm me I will not tell on
you but when you're coming I'll actually
feed you for the night let you sleep and
go on and these patterns are well
understood but you know it's it's
distrust between authorities and local
people yeah that's one major source of
contention here yeah you know the the
other thing is I'm not suggesting
technology is the answer to this big
problem it's a very small element at the
bottom of the response ironically but
it's a necessary element and that's the
part that we are focused on yeah so so
here is just to get you to visualize
what's happening in South Africa so so
about I would say five or six kilometers
from this River area is a is a guard
station the guard stations on the top of
a hill it has this tall chimney on the
tall chimney we've got a base station
going yes now this base station has got
line-of-sight visibility to a bunch of
abutting hills these hills could be two
kilometres three kilometres four
kilometres away so we can create single
low-power links to them these routers to
which the first hop links are could be
put on poles they could be put on trees
and now in these at these tops of these
hills we somehow have to go down into
the valley so that we can communicate
with the sensors which are placed along
the river yeah the sensors are you know
yeh scale size is not an issue we didn't
really have to go much smaller and in
fact in you know perhaps in our earlier
deployments we even had this
right so you can mount these on on
little branches on on little trees and
you put them at a certain height you
don't want the radar in this case to be
at ground level but but here we had a
solution which was roughly on this form
factor now a little bit of a background
on how radars work so essentially this
is a micro power Doppler radar so it's
not a continuous wave you're shouting
out pulses right pulses are sent at a
high frequency you can send them million
or two or three million times a second
that's the pulse repetition frequency
yeah so this generated this is a very
old concept of radar which is called
homodyning radar that when these went
these multiple pulses this is an example
of a single pulse is shouted you know it
travels to the target the reflection
comes back and the reflection is
convolve with duplicate of the
transmitted pulse yeah and that
convolution contains the information
that you're looking for so so we are
running at what might be a few percent
of duty cycle of a continuous wave and
you're shouting out something that's
very low power so the overall power
consumption is not too much yeah that
said this is the biggest consumer of
power in our system you know over the
years we've had many versions of the
radar we started off with 30 milli watt
went to 40 milli watt and finally have
been able to pull that back to around 16
milli watt and we think we have designs
which will go down to a couple of
billion what but that's going to be real
research so so you have you have this
big power consumer but still in the low
power regime which which we are going to
analyze our information from and here I
spoke to this a little bit yesterday but
what you have is this complex return and
this complex return as the target
approaches you know has this particular
pattern which grows stronger and the
phase rotates and the rotation of the
phase gives you a sense of how much
distance is traveled
yeah so so this by itself is an
interesting feature to begin with so if
you look at the nature of the clutter
response the clutter response which is
all these bushes and trees around the
radar are actually not producing much
change in phase this phase is self
cancelling but if a human or a target
not of interest goes through the scene
that is a displacing object something
that's not moving in in situ
and you can see that there is a
significant change in the phase which we
can track so you've got a basis for
starting on discriminating objects but
if you want to get finer grain then you
can look at not just the amplitude and
the phase signatures you can look at the
time frequency signatures so here are
signatures of how a car which is a rigid
object corresponds to a very narrow band
of excited frequencies yeah
but the human which and a dog which is a
soft target have this much richer
frequency spread and within this
frequency spread although not very
nicely visible at this resolution are
very interesting micro Doppler patterns
you can see not just a torso you can see
the limbs you can actually discriminate
the arms and the legs and in fact that
becomes a basis from discriminating from
the dog because the the feet typically
are much more spindly and therefore you
don't have much return from from the
legs so this is frequency right and what
we are seeing is the the frequencies
which are excited over time right so so
the this is the Doppler shift precisely
yeah now how do you classify it I will
not spend much time on this you track
the displacement and you can reject
things which are moving in Scituate on
that previously explained idea of how
the displacement and revs whereas in
situ movements do not traverse much
distance and then you run this support
vector machine which leverages a bunch
of features that we have
and it took a while to lay out something
like 80 features here is an example of a
feature which says that what is the area
of excitation above a certain threshold
in the spectrogram and so for a dog that
that anomaly area is much smaller than
for a human target and we hope this is
an interesting feature we have no idea
whether it'll work we throw data at it
and we look at you know the relevance of
these features how much information gain
they have and we try to select features
and then we of course implement this and
details of that are not relevant at the
moment any questions before I really
begin yes so this is the story I would
like to tell in the next few slides the
aspiration is I will collect data from
multiple clutters multiple backgrounds
on multiple targets on multiple
instances of radar of different
generations and come up with a
classifier that works for all that's the
aspiration yeah and the story I'd like
to tell is well which parts we succeeded
on which parts are are still moving but
the brief answer is for the longest time
you've stuck with one classifier for all
environments yeah that's that's the
thing we're working towards
yeah okay so so let's begin by saying
well clutters are very different yeah so
so here is the response in terms of
amplitude sorry this is hard to read
amplitude of Grass amplitude in a more
idealized setting where one would
imagine there are no reflectors like you
know just tarmac
this is an airport where we do
experiments for DARPA and and here is
the the change in phase over time that
axis is called rotations per second so
the unwrapped number of rotations per
second gives you a sense of how phase is
changing and as you can see these are
significantly different and both the
amplitude and the phase domain I don't
know if it's absolutely visible but they
are yeah so now now the target returns
will be superposed on these variable
clutter returns
and the thinking is it's possible if
you've collected it enough diverse
environments to estimate a worst case
background clutter and to choose a
displacement threshold for targets in in
these background clutters which will
lead to a constant number of fall salons
so the the false alarm rate will be
constant so we want to allow something
like one a month or one a year yeah and
and that at at this point of description
is feasible yeah so I'll give a chart to
that momentarily that's the simple
explanation the more interesting
explanation is you would have thought
that grass is you know there's more time
more clutter in grass than in the
idealized concrete so you should have
had higher noise in the grass case turns
out it's the opposite and a lot of that
has to do with the implementation of the
radar the particular choice of the
components and how the inter mods etc
get affected by these targets so in fact
concrete is an environment in which the
rate the phase noise drifts whereas when
there is more clutter the phase noise
actually tends to become quiescent yeah
counterintuitive but again something
unanticipated now if we just step back
from clutter and just look at the
underlying board noise the underlying
board noise itself has varied
significantly across various generations
so this is a very recent radar the 16
milli watt Raider I was referring to
where the median of the amplitude in
this is just plain simple noise is you
know this number 10 yeah whereas the
radar that we put in in South Africa the
median of that is substantially higher
at 70 2.4 yeah and conversely when you
look at the rotations you'll see that
the noise the noise rotations are higher
for this radar as well so for different
radars we have to be able to tolerate
this underlying noise and the way we do
that is by doing an online estimation of
the background noise yeah so so you
maintain this estimate of the background
amplitude and what you say is
I'm going to choose some number that I
have learned yeah some some estimate
some functional estimate of the
background noise which if it shows up in
a return I will treat that as noise and
I will reject that that sample so I'm
actually going to be throwing away
samples which correspond to what by and
hypothesizing is a noise return yeah now
the net effect of that is that of course
you're actually throwing away some
signal returns you've got soft targets
the soft target amplitudes will vary
some of those soft target returns we
will throw away yeah so we are going to
underestimate our displacement and so
the learning of the displacement
threshold now gets coupled with the
sample rejection threshold yeah so
around 2010 what we found was that in
many environments if you know this is
like an empty field there's a parking
garage there lots of trees grasses
different places and we found that a
single threshold could give you this
constant false alarm but as we went to
generations of the radar where the noise
grew a lot that that gave us a
displacement threshold where we started
to have false negatives so we had to
introduce this concept of background
rejection and after we do background
rejection and all of the environments
we've collected data on that that
technique will work so we've come up
with this online algorithm for for
estimating the noise and seeing what and
having trained for various levels of
noise for various levels of rejection
what the threshold is going to be so so
here what we have is a log scale which
says the probability of the false alarm
as a function of the distance that is
traversed yeah so so what this is saying
is you know if you look at a case where
you have trees you know the probability
of the false alarm drops more quickly so
it in order to get in order to reject
tree movement
a threshold of 0.17 meters would have
been sufficient to give you a
probability of false alarm which was
significantly less than one false alarm
a week or one false alarm month yeah but
you'd have to use a larger threshold to
reject whatever this this parking garage
one is yeah and so as the noise
increased for us this threshold that we
had to reject became something like
point six five meters and that was
competing with what actual displacements
on targets were so he would have gotten
false positives false negatives yeah so
in order to rein in the false negative
we introduced the background rejection
and then chose this Universal threshold
that here what we are saying is
something like point four meters is
sufficient to reject to reject clutter
in these different environments yes yes
this is the the phase shift yeah in in
in rotations yes yes in in a window
exactly precisely yeah so the window of
course is dictated by the windows that
we use for discriminating displacement
right and they're also you know we've
got to build in the fact that our
targets are not moving continuously they
pause yeah they will change orientation
so we have to introduce some techniques
for for handling those cases in those
windows so in fact I suspect those ideas
may be relevant for you but we can take
that offline yes this data set includes
you know high wind presence of rain
moving water nearby in the scene etc
yeah so this is painful right we have to
collect all this data yeah now so to get
to Shu shus question you know the the
question is how do you design a
classifier which works in a new
environment which you haven't
encountered before and the very simple
observation is trying not to train from
data collected in similar environments
there is a real gap
between the performance that you expect
to get between a system which has been
trained for different environments
versus a system which has been trained
in similar environments yeah so we
started doing designs where we are
looking at what the cross environmental
information gain of a feature is and
that leads to this very simple idea but
maybe I'll spell it out so here is a
feature which is not robust if you look
at frequency noise and you look at the
volume of frequency of the of the energy
in this spectral domain above a certain
threshold that can change quite
substantially so it's not a robust
feature but if you look at just project
that area factor that that's that that
object of that spectral power of
activation above a threshold into the
area or the shape of that activation
then that seems to be much more robust
so we'd like to find in our feature
selection not just features which have
high information gain but which are
likely to show very low variance across
different environments and so that led
to this work where we came up with
techniques for for starting off with
things like mrr mrr
information gain or information gain but
then actually pruning out those features
by adding this dispersion component
which we called you know the mean
absolute deviation and we are trying to
to basically minimize this variance and
that's modeled by throwing in this hyper
parameter which takes into account the
relative importance of the information
gain and the variability so roughly
speaking a very simple idea is choose
those features which are going to have
low variance across environments while
not losing information too much so
that's the the answer to your question
now we run into cases which are more
interesting yeah so the first case
the case where assume that the pulse is
generated by a radar periodic yeah
assumed accidentally the pulse is
generated by two radar are perfectly
aligned yeah now the return of a target
from radar one might show up in the in
in the reference pulses which are you
know convolve for radar - so now targets
which are potentially not even in the
scene of radar one are sorry not in the
scene of radar two are showing up
because radar one is exciting them yeah
so so that's the problem that shouldn't
be allowed right normally we don't
really place radars very close to each
other if I'm counting the number of
people in this room one radar should be
sufficient but you know if there's a
neighboring room which has its own radar
the question is am I seeing the targets
there in my return here yeah and the way
you typically handle this is by D
synchronizing the pulses and that's
where software control becomes helpful
yeah so how much randomness you want to
create what patterns you want to create
become something that you program now
another topic is as we get to it's one
thing to say a single target displaced
through the scene and the phase unwrap
nicely but what happens if multiple
targets are in the scene yeah the simple
case is when one target is somehow
dominant it's close to you and
essentially what you're tracking is that
one target but if there are cases where
you want to count and the other target
is behind the dominant target how do you
how do you discover that and so we did
some work on counting classifiers
actually regression functions for
counting where the very very high-level
summary is first of all the longer you
observe the more likely the hidden the
obfuscated targets will reveal
themselves kind of counterintuitive but
it took us a little while to discover
that and the second one was that there
are certain features where you can look
at you know shadows of objects yeah
hidden imprints of objects so we
discovered the need
looking in the spectrogram for gradients
so you had this this strong return this
area of excitation but you also saw that
there was a there was you know there was
a smooth not too sharp gradient besides
it which was indicative of some other
objects which were there and so you
started using those gradient features to
build your estimates of the number of
people so here is a sir any questions on
that idea really these are separate
pieces of work and I'm not explaining
them at much length yes yes it depends
on your application so in in in the
sensor I was describing for this room
that's really about counting the
utilization of the room so we can do
various things you know we could decide
how much air to pump through a room
based on its utilization and that's an
energy saving so so yes sometimes you
really do want to count a number of
targets another example is this bike
pedestrian network that we are deploying
where we want sort of multiple points of
utilization across a trail network
currently that's not very well handled
you know what you have is data from
phones right where people who are going
through those trails are self reporting
but you don't know what fraction of the
population is doing that very well to
build your estimates and and the other
technologies are quite manual so the
planning in a city like Columbus is
largely based on trying out some
technologies but actually depending on
human counts than twice a year to
estimate which trails are being used
which ones to fix etcetera so we'd like
to actually do a you know low cost
counting at multiple points in the in
the trail network and and here you know
this problem of obfuscation is basic for
us
now there is a different form of
obfuscation which is you know somewhat
privacy centric so here I'll be I'll be
describing you know radar like
classification but I'll be doing it in
the traditional comms domain so in the
recent several years there's been a
bunch of work where people have looked
at wireless signals and you look at the
side channel of the wireless signal in
some sense by you know extracting the
low frequency components of the signal
out of it by integrating a number of
samples and so just like we were using a
basis for recognizing that there was a
target and the seen by a radar you can
look at the Wi-Fi calls which are
reflecting of this target to
discriminate is there a person in this
room yeah or how many people are there
in this room now supposing I want to
hide the fact that somebody outside can
can observe outside my house can observe
how many whether somebody is at home or
not
how would I do that yeah so that's this
this concept which I call obfuscation so
so the idea is something like this if
you look at what the this is the signal
being transmitted this is the signal
being received either at the Wi-Fi
receiver or at your sensor that depends
you know that has these three degrees of
freedom so the target influences the
amplitude it influences the Doppler
shift and it influences the propagation
delay yeah so have these three degrees
of freedom and I don't know what sensor
this is going to be used but the sensor
is somehow going to use some combination
of information in these three degrees of
freedom so what I would like to do is to
somehow obscure the information in these
degrees as follows
yeah so what I'm going to do is to
introduce yet another node that I call
an obfuscator which is going to transmit
copies of the incoming signal so this
signal is being sent in in parallel to
the this the transmission signal right
all has to be you know constructive in
some sense so we are using for this
obfuscator and implementation which is
based on full duplex radios so in this
copy that we are going to relay we are
going to perturb in these three
dimensions we're going to put the by
adding an amplitude component you're
going to further by adding a potentially
different Doppler component and a
different phase component yeah and so
the net result is that instantaneously
we can distort the amplitude in the
phase but there it turns out that you
know in the in the frequency that is
still discriminable and in order to
compensate for that the rate at which
you distort becomes relevant so as long
as you are distorting at a rate which is
faster than what the sensor was trying
to use then you should be sufficient
there are some very interesting details
about how the full duplex deals with
self cancellation which I'm not going to
talk about but the interesting thing is
this an obfuscator can itself prevent a
sensor from working while itself being
able to sense so we can create
legitimate sensors while simultaneously
obfuscating illegitimate sensors without
by the way affecting communication and
that's a whole other story
yeah the communication rate in fact
doesn't go down it goes up because we
are in fact relaying yes yes of course
yes of course yeah
so this is always a cat-and-mouse game
and this research itself is pure cat and
mouse because I'm talking about you know
a single sensor a single antenna sensor
if you've got a distributed array of
observers then this this technique per
se is not sufficient we have to move to
the next level in that game of of
obfuscation and so here is sort of
showing how you know as you introduce
distortions and copies what
as the granularity of what happens to
the granularity of the spectrogram sir
as the Doppler shift changes yeah so
this higher rate of change will will
will give you a result something like
this
let's assume this is the pattern that
the sensor was looking for after
obfuscation you know you've essentially
removed the components in in every part
of this so that that pattern should no
longer be discoverable so we gave
implementations of high cloak and we
showed how they performed in in in at
least in the lab setting yeah so an
interesting comment there is much of the
technology actually it's harder to make
it robust across different environments
for sensing but it's easier to obfuscate
it that problem is easier because all
I'm doing is I'm being destructive yeah
in the sensing domain not the
communication domain yes yes this is all
RF right yeah and in the radar you can
actually do something similar which is
you can inject signatures so if I know
what signature is to be expected by a
sensor I can pretend that there is
somebody in the room by spoofing that
yeah I can my approve my obfuscator can
now become a spoofer and and this is an
example of a lab of a measured spoofing
to show how you could emulate a
particular gesture like like a poll so
the last topic I'd like to focus on in
terms of limited signal is how do we
deal with the lack of data this is a
problem we all face you know we go
around buildings in different ways and
collect information malls forests etc
but it's really there's a lot of
problems in this process and most
importantly its inefficient so the cost
of this process is quite high yeah so so
you know in Chandigarh we collected data
on tigers and bears and
I forget the third elephants yeah you
know this may be murder Pradesh and we
didn't get fantastic data at all
Tigers are very lazy in the afternoon
yeah you don't want to collect data on
Tigers in zoos yeah so we're really for
building a tiger versus human classifier
I need data from from from elsewhere
yeah and then the impact of not having
data is quite simple you know here for
example is you remember the face chart I
showed you for a human and a ball right
here is the time frequency component for
a for a large ball which is seen close
to the radar versus a human that's quite
far away from the radar and you know
from a pattern perspective they look
quite similar so if I didn't have
sufficient data on weak humans this
classifier would likely have made a
mistake
yeah conversely what we find is that
sometimes a single parameter for our
features is not enough you need multiple
parameters for your feature to actually
capture the variability of targets so to
be able to capture both this strong ball
and the weak ball I might need multiple
parameter instances and if I don't have
a rich enough data set I don't capture
that fact yeah now the problem is almost
wicked because your targets are quite
variable in size they actually walk
quite differently men and women and
children walk differently their speeds
tend to be quite variable their
trajectories are quite unknown they
could be stopping turning you know dogs
like to just go around in circles you
know and that's having good time and
their activities while they're doing
this can be changing quite a bit so you
need that variability built in into your
data collect now what solve worse is if
the problem is almost inverted because
we've collected data from radars which
were placed as I was telling you at
about three feet but what if a radar is
placed at eight feet right that because
you know in in the in the vertical
dimension it's it's a thirty degree
angle
and so the response that you would get
would be very elevation dependent the
orientation of the radar matters just as
well because it aspires to be an
omnidirectional sensor but it is not
exactly one it has got strong front
lobes somewhat strong back lobes and
weaker side lobes so the gain in
different directions is different and
then as I told you the noise
characteristics can be different and
across builds the wavelength can be
different say why yes yes there the
innate aspires to be an omni direction
but it has artifacts in it yeah so even
the central front lobe is somewhat
left-leaning right this has to do with
sort of board capacitance effects and
and all of that yeah and in how well
impedance matching is done so what we
would really like to do is to augment
our data synthetically and I'd like to
describe you know our evolution and
augmenting data starting from something
trivial to something more interesting so
so here's a trivial idea to get the
stage set right so so the radar is not
exactly omnidirectional so you've got
different games so if I have a radar
file of a target going on a radio where
I know how much it's gain is larger than
another radio so this is this is
controlled data's right where a human is
walking along a certain radio and if I
just simply very sorry if I vary the
gain I can produce the same behavior on
a different orientation it's not a
trivial idea yeah now slightly more
interesting is that if I focus on the
target was walking with the uniform
speed big if yeah then I can come up
with a data set which works at a
different speed by actually up sampling
or down sampling yeah that turns out to
be conservative this one you know as we
test in training it has it is slightly
less useful than the previous one
precisely no no no so we are starting
off with the data set some of which is
controlled and well labeled and we are
using that data through these primitive
models and they are primitive trust me
to generate other data yeah and and you
if you generalize this idea and you've
got walks in different directions some
along radio's some along orthogonals
different radials you can synthesize
pieces and come up with arbitrary
trajectories so you can come up with a
richer data set which is what you know
this last one was trying to spell out
and in the interest of time I won't
spell it out it's really very simple
physics actually the stuff is not great
at all right because a lot of our
features are looking for micro Doppler
yeah I modeled house how the gross body
speed would show up in this other walk
but what about the micro Doppler what
have I done to it I may have you
actually distorted it in a way that was
counterproductive so so what this has
led us to is to rethinking how we
generate our synthetic data and so what
we are doing now is to say we need a
source where we have well labeled data
from a CO sensor in this case what we
are doing is you know we have video
which is giving us you know these these
temporal sequences of labelled
information now then what we would like
to do from this this Co sensor we would
like to extract from that the positions
the orientations the sizes of the
various components and then and then
from that we should be able to generate
via radar simulation models our traces
so so to keep this somewhat basic to
begin with we start off
with video from that video we extract
position orientation other information
and then we feed that into knowing all
the components of the foreground and
perhaps some components of the
background we can superpose all those
returns and come up with the radar
return doing something like that in in a
radar simulation toolbox MATLAB
now that idea itself can be made a
little bit richer by throwing in various
model parameters so here even the video
has been captured at a certain height at
a certain orientation often from a fixed
camera but I want to try various other
orientations and elevations so now I can
augment the model that I'm using for
generating the radar data and create
many more simulations out of that yeah
so so somewhat pictorially speaking you
know we had two approaches to collecting
video data
one is using this motion capture motion
capture you actually get data for humans
for dogs for vehicles this is somewhat
publicly available sometimes you have to
pay for it yeah so this is nicely
labeled data where you've got you know
the the body components marked in it
from which skeleton data can be
extracted and similarly even with the
Kinect you can come up with skeleton
data now these joints can be converted
into the into can be treated as the
ellipsoids and you can estimate the
limber ellipsoids for that and that can
be used to generate your radar
simulation yeah conversely you can
decompose you know the video into you
know polygons and for each polygon
element you can look at what its
response is going to be and superpose
those responses in your radar simulation
now having generated all that that data
you can now try you know creating other
model instances by throwing in the
parameter variations from some set and
come up with a richer set
now we're at the point where we have we
are looking at the accuracy of this
Richard generation
it looks quite promising and coming into
this workshop we had this debate about
whether we should use synthetic data or
not and we think we're not using it now
but we think we should be using it
because it's it is accurate enough okay
so that was the story I wanted to share
about limited signals and roughly I'd
like to conclude by looking ahead on
where we ought to be focusing so one
thing to ask is you know we've had these
somewhat primitive ways of dealing with
limited signal for shallow learning but
these issues are going to be handled
must be handled in the deep learning
work so how does deep learning provide
us a good basis for handling limited
signal issues bunch of questions there I
think which should be interesting
research but the other thing that we
have learnt and this goes back to sure
share your question is it the right
thing to learn a classifier that works
across all backgrounds that works across
all locations that works across all
radar technologies and we're coming to
the point where that's not the right
answer so we'll have to specialize the
sensor yeah based on its type based on
its location and some of this is going
to involve online learning so of course
we need the basis by which sensors can
share their model drift with the cloud
and the cloud can come up with new
general models for everyone or more
interestingly you can do federated
learning so what we are running into a
case is why every sensor is estimating
its own background
it needs a basis for you being able to
relearn its model and that can be done
locally and/or assisted by the cloud so
what are the patterns for that so those
I think are going to be very interesting
for limited signals so with that I'll be
happy to take questions
[Music]
no actually Sonic so I'm you know
yesterday I spoke about this sounds of
New York City project which I didn't
have time to explain today but the the
situation there is you're placing
sensors in very different parts of the
city so some can be in urban canyons
some can be in city parks right some can
be in in housing areas which are you
know a mixture of trees and and low
buildings so in all of these the
propagation characteristics will be
quite different it turns out we do have
information about these different parts
of the city which can be used to model
how sound will propagate so we have
folks on the data analytics side and the
visualization side who can tell us what
we think propagation characteristics
would be yeah so that can be given as
input to your your cloud learner yeah
but the the other question that we can
ask is how can a sensor at a given
location notice that things have changed
enough enough foliage has changed that
my model is no longer working and become
a basis for triggering yeah or can a
sensor benefit from sharing its what's
the right word
it's let's call it mode yeah I hesitate
to use context in this case range so we
could have we could have our
classification outputs be done for
different modes and can a sensor provide
its mode to its neighbors as a way of
informing them which might be the
relevant classifier to use so we are
basically exploring a number of options
for handling the drift of the model of
any of a local sensor yeah and one thing
that I'm trying to do is to provide the
plumbing to support that learning right
so we're reserving enough energy budget
for sharing data snippets which are
indicative that my model seemed to you
know had low confidence in assessing
this particular data item so how does
this inform the learning of the regional
or the global model it's quite possible
like I mentioned we have 30 years of
data so we have data from let's say 50
to 100 locations which are telling us
over two years how the how the soil how
the sound characteristics changed so but
that yeah so assuming that that data
gets labeled and that labeling is
trustworthy perhaps that can be done
yeah now how how predictive that is of
next year or next spring I don't know
and that takes me down this road of
actually just being able to recognize
what mode I mean yeah if I can recognize
what mode I mean I can see which
classifier to bring in from a library of
classifiers
okay so so I'm still trying to parse
your question so so perhaps I can I can
talk about the difference between
cellular modeling and low-power sense
low-power RF modeling in you know as a
way of starting the conversation so so
very good planning tools exist for how
cellular characteristics will be across
a region and they can tolerate
typography quite well and it's probably
because they're in a different SNR
regime yeah when we try to use the
similar planning ideas for deploying our
relays in South Africa it turned out
that we were quite bad and estimating
what would work so let me just
illustrate that so in a low-power regime
where you can very quickly go from
constructive to destructive interference
moving a radar by three or four feet
actually half a wavelength can take you
from district instructed to destructive
right but what we found was that I had
to search in that region to find a spot
where I could deploy my radar yeah so
one would have predicted that going down
a hill with this medium amount of
vegetation should have given you 300
meters of range but that was not enough
then you had to do this search which was
extremely painful when you're climbing
trees yeah so as I I don't know how easy
it is in this low power regime to do
what you're saying
well you know for years I had my boys
trying to behave like dogs when we were
collecting data it is not really easy
yeah so I'm going to sort of distort
your question the question is how would
you fool this radar what are the ways of
fooling it so one way of fooling it is
to actually move extremely slowly so
when you look at special operations
people they can sometimes move a metre
an hour when they are crossing very
sensitive borders right this thing is
sensitive up to two point six
centimeters per second right but a metre
an hour is much slower than two point
six centimeters so you're obscured yeah
the other thing you can do is to be
extremely fast right so the way the
filters on the radar are set you can
pick up just two point six meters a
second and really about five meters a
second but it's possible to run faster
than five meters a second it's a way of
avoiding this yeah you know our we are
banking on the fact that this poacher is
going through this densely wooded forest
it seen right through these narrow
trails is actually coming into this
hidden way and will we get picked up but
if you're doing the same thing with cars
this probably will not work yes
yes yeah you know it has not affected us
significantly yeah so what I am
reporting are cases where we have
deployed sensors far too close where we
see a little bit of observation of a
target even before it enters the scene
that observation is not very predictable
yeah so sometimes it looks like a clear
target sometimes it doesn't look like a
clear target yeah so what I'm saying is
that this is not a major problem for us
in practice and it's a manageable
problem in part because we program
things as it is it's a very low
probability that the periodic pulses
will line up right and we are also
throwing in randomness and randomness is
good because it makes your radar
stealthy right so it's harder to see the
pulse pattern you need a higher order
detector to know the presence of the
radar so so yeah for us it hasn't been a
major problem but we are seeing
instances of this and are in our
training data and the question is how
much is it affecting our training data
is what we are trying to to establish
right now so my interest isn't seeing if
I can if I can classify it and prune it
so that I'm only learning from clean
data at the moment yes okay good
question so so I think the biggest
source of false alarms has not been
environmental it's been radar design
Isha's yeah so if you've got a radar
which has got unusually high noise and
we haven't gotten the thresholds right
for that right that's where the false
positives tend to occur for us but oh
yeah maybe I should I should give
another example so the World Wildlife
Fund tested our system which was doing a
human versus a cattle classifier and
they took it onto a horse farm and they
tested it with horses yeah and they said
yeah you know I'm seeing humans all the
time with horses you know your system
doesn't work so so that I don't know how
to parse the system wasn't designed to
discriminate horses as horses yeah so so
that has caused some confusion right so
if we are deploying this in an
environment where you know we've trained
for cattle and goats on one side and
humans and dogs on the other side and
all of a sudden this this Rhino starts
showing up we don't know what's gonna
happen right so that can be viewed as a
false positive in the system so that
that operator ratio we we have today
okay this is not a rangering radar yes
so what it lets you do is to look at the
relative distance not the absolute
distance now if you you could do very
coarse localization because for example
in panda the way it was set up was we
knew there was Australian close to a
village which meant a certain distance
so you were actually putting sensors
along the trail yeah so in that setting
ear you already know where the nodes are
located and you're within a few meters
of that and that is sufficient but more
importantly you've got actually multiple
sensors observing so you can be you can
be more exact yeah but but yeah so
conversely there's a lot of research on
very accurate localization with ultra
wideband radar there's a lot of
literature on that if you're interested
one of my students proble data has
written some papers on that you
certainly can and it costs a lot of
power gps will take you yeah yeah the
triangulation is certainly the way you
you handle localization the question is
how do you get your range estimates so
you can go to a ranging radar
and one reason we introduced the FPGA
was so that we could create very narrow
range gates so right now the way the
radar works is roughly one-and-a-half
meters from the radar to about 1213
meters is is everything there is treated
as one response but you can create range
gates which are about a meter long so
now you can create 12 such rain gates
and you can sweep the radar through each
of them and then you can localize within
that distance right but that's a 1 meter
it's about a half a meter error rate on
average whereas what folks and
localization are trying to do are to get
sub centimeter localization accuracy so
that's a slightly richer that's a harder
problem you know we are this is centered
at 5.8 gigahertz it's a medium bandwidth
so it's about a hundred megahertz
bandwidth yeah there's not an ultra
wideband radar but it still got rich
information
that's a good question yet we have
significant experience with that so we
coexist with Wi-Fi and Bluetooth without
being affected yeah very good thanks a
lot
[Applause]